did you ever think you would make it I
feel I'm so I tastet Victory I know this
life
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David valueing giv values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the one
he was right around the time of Garnett
okay episode 341 special guest today
kamaro Usman uh some call him Marty some
call him the uh uh the Nigerian
Nightmare uh very one of the most
exciting Fighters I've seen fight over
the last few years and it's great to
have you on the podcast man thank you
thank you how you feeling how you doing
I'm good I'm good yeah so I I so we just
obviously we just had this the recent
card and Edwards went against Kobe and I
know you had a very interesting Exchange
withier where you're giving him
perspectives on who you think was going
to win the fight and it was very very
interesting how you guys were having to
debate The Exchange and you're like no
I'm telling you I think this is what's
going to happen the challenge of being
off and the cardio the role it plays etc
etc you were being very matter of fact
and I had a couple questions for you
which we'll get into is at what level is
the [__] talking cross the line like is
there a limit in it which we'll get into
that but uh aside from that first things
first Nigerian Nightmare where did that
nickname start that happens to be just a
nickname that I always heard as a child
growing up and it was kind of a nickname
that
just uh every athlete that was
just I guess more than exceptional in
their field that's a nickname you wanted
if you're Nigerian born that's the
nickname you wanted it was just it's
it's it was like a a pride flag that we
just carried everywhere because you
wanted them to know that you were a
nightmare in your sport and so there's
been there's been multiple Nigerian
nightmares there's been you know soccer
players that were Nigerian nightmar who
were who are the famous Nigerian
Nightmare uh Christian AO in American
football he was a Nigerian Nightmare
everyone knew what a nightmare CH Kansas
City Chiefs everybody knew what a
nightmare he was to tackle Samuel Peters
WBC heavyweight champion of the world
boxing you know a lot of people don't
know that name cuz he you know he didn't
hold a title for very very long but yeah
he was a nightmare you know to deal with
so there there have been a few Nigerian
nightmares but these are some of the
athletes that I grew up watching and it
was just a name that it was just like if
I ever got an opportunity to carry that
flag and represent that name I want it
but then you know I was wrestling and
and wrestling it's not you know not as
mainstream enough to where you get to
really use that name and then I got into
fighting I'm like oh man this perfect
opportunity take it so I I I took it
right away but the thing the the biggest
thing about it is you got to live up to
it yeah and so you know you're starting
out and you're just thinking ah okay I
just need to win a fight maybe win the
next fight then next thing you know it's
like hey I'm I'm not doing too bad at
this maybe I I've got something here now
you know the world knows that name and
it's like oh yeah I did it definitely
did it justice that's a that's a good a
good point so Vinnie who is the Assyrian
or the Jewish nightmares like who I me
like the Armenian assassin I don't even
know who who I don't know I don't know
if the nightmare goes I think the
Assassin goes with Syrian or the
Armenian assassin like the the dream I
like he's a cute I don't know I don't
know about the I know the Jewish
nightmare would be Sasha Baron con
that's who it is you know I
mean it's like oh [__] you mess around
with that guy you're going to find out
so so so everybody's got a we had in
ganu here in Francis and he's telling a
story and what a crazy story he's got
right and for you your story is uh is
also an interesting one who you grew up
with your father your mother I think
your father is a uh Muslim your mother
Christian you're grown up in that
environment and your dad I believe was a
pharmacist and you told a story one time
to Mike about how he would get angry he
would get upset with Mike Tyson where
you guys are watching a fight and let me
go get a beer or drink and he comes back
to fights he's pissed off what the hell
is going on here tell us a little bit
about the upbringing of kamaru Usman and
then how that led into fighting yeah um
it was was just great you know I knew I
knew my mom and dad you know something
that you know a lot of you know kids
nowadays don't necessarily get that
pleasure of of being around a two parent
household or having both parents in
their lives but grew up with Mom and Dad
and you know it was great I I never you
know when you're a kid you just you
don't know what you don't know you're
just living life and my father's Muslim
mom's a Christian never an argument
never a problem really never a problem
about religion not once you know the
boys it was three boys growing up you
know for a while the boys just we did
what Dad did we went you know went to
the MOs we was raised that way and then
we immigrated here to the states where
my mom would go to church on Sunday
and after a while I think it just became
one of those good here in American you
know Sundays that's that's football day
you know I think it kind of got to a
point
where that's time for us to all right go
with your mom disappear for a couple
hours you know Dad potentially gets to
just be home by himself watch football
so that was never it wasn't an issue for
us to go to church with her so you know
gradually we started going to church and
now we're introduced to a whole another
you know religion and and all of that
even though it's it's a different
religion there's so many similarities to
where I think it was absolutely just the
best way because now as an adult I have
you know I have that mindset to be able
to make an informed decision for myself
of if I want to be a Muslim or a
Christian or respect both which is I
have great respect for both religions so
that was just special to me now looking
back and seeing what you know my parents
did at that time which doubt about it
that's yeah which I'm sure that it
wasn't planned but which there like they
say there's no you know handbook to
Parenting but it just worked out
amazingly and remember you know my
fathers we used to would order the
fights growing up and you know Tyson was
was that guy that every of course is
Mike
Tyson and my Dad loved to have fight
parties M hm so he would have a fight
party and all his friends are there and
we're just kids so kids aren't
necessarily allowed in the in the living
room but of course we knew what was
going on and we wanted to see what was
going on too and there was one
particular that I remembered I think it
was um I can't remember what fight it
was but it would I mean like most Tyson
fights very quick and so you know things
are going on we're waiting for you know
things to happen and the last fight
before Co was done and then I was Tyson
and he's walking out and my dad's like
oh he's walking out and everything's all
right let me run in the garage and grab
a beer cuz you know you know we have
that you know you have that you have to
have that backup fridge in the in the
garage extra beers go back there course
we all know that so he goes in let's get
get some drinks for his buddy cuz my dad
loves to entertain
and on his way back he hears screaming
he runs in the garage what happened what
happened fight's over oh oh man oh my
dad's
pissed like most people were back then
cuz you know when you pay that what was
it $39.99 back then for a Tyson fight
and it's over yeah most people were
pissed he he pissed off a lot of people
Mike Tyson one of those first round
Knockouts 10 second Knockouts sometimes
back to your father cuz you were talking
about you're a father now right you have
one I have one daughter you have one
daughter um who was the leader in your
household growing up because you seem to
be like probably the leader in your
household your father's Muslim your
mother's
Christian who was the leader in the
family what's the role of the father how
are you embracing what your father
taught you with mother taught you and
bringing that into your child's life my
father of course I I I come from a
traditional family I'm was raised around
that I saw that growing up
and that's how it always worked you know
and my father's you know the leader my
father goes out and and and I guess with
you know if you want to bring it back in
the Primal days you know goes out and
kills the kills the meat and drags it
back and feeds the family and my mom was
her role was so important because if the
father's not at home and the kids are
are starting to grow and they maturing
there's got to be someone that that has
that level of of understanding and
respect for what the father's doing
outside that's that's rearing these
children at home and letting them know
that's what your father's doing that's
how important what your father's doing
is to what we do here and keeping the
kids in line as far as raising them and
and helping them grow and understand
that as well because if that's not
that's not there the father could be out
you know accumulating or doing whatever
he needs to do but if that respect is
and that's not being built and
cultivated at home the kids aren't going
to respect what you're doing out that
they don't care because kids don't care
you can have all the money in the world
but if you're never there kids don't
care what would what would your mother
say to edify your father so when he got
home that was respect what would your
father say to you guys to respect your
mother how did that all work I mean We
There was my father didn't have to say
much you knew yeah you we're not you're
not going to disrespect M strong
personality tough yeah my dad was a a
major in the Nigerian Army before coming
here and then he was also in the
military here and then went became a
pharmacist in the military so both
countries he served yeah oh wow and and
so
um my he was just a my dad was just that
military kind of guy you know didn't
didn't really laugh much but not is not
for me as a kid growing up you know it
seemed like he was always just Stone
face but you know looking back at it
there was it was just lessons and
lessons that you don't realize until you
become an adult yourself but raising
three boys I'm sure it wasn't the
easiest I bet I can I can only uh and by
the way your brothers are is are all
three Fighters or what do the other two
no my my oldest brother uh Dr uh cash to
Usman was uh he's a doctor in Pharmacy
and he was a uh soccer player so he
played uh played in college and played
semipro and until he decided to go back
to school and become a pharmacist so
that's what he's doing now and and now
branching off and getting into the
business world as well and into real
estate development uh my younger brother
was a football player who was he's the
bigger one and he played at you
University of Houston then played uh
finished up at the University of
Arizona and just you know had it bounced
around some pro teams a little bit and
then uh decided that he wanted to start
fighting so now he's also in the UFC oh
really oh wow so he's uh's slowly
building his own uh his own resume what
position in football and what weight
class in fighting now he was a defensive
end oh big boy so defensive end
linebacker so he was in he was one of
those in between guys I think maybe
250 about 63 I think he was fast and and
he was one of those you know head first
kind of guy he's that's your so uh yeah
so he um he had the speed to get around
gu so he could he could to put put his
hand down or or or run around he's a
heavyweight is that what he call yeah
he's a heavyweight sure he's a
heavyweight but he's also he's also a
tweener he he could uh obviously if
there was a 220 weight class that's
where he would be but he he fights at
about now when he's really physically
fit in his shape he's probably about 235
and you guys train together what's that
relationship like now not really not
trying to mess with your brother or what
he not trying to mess with you that work
no it's it's of course we could like I'm
I'm still big brother and I I'm I'm
skilled in being able to handle myself
but obviously he's he's growing and he's
getting better and so when he gets to
the point where he has as much knowledge
as I have then it's going to be a
problem come on were you were you were
you were you ever bullied when you were
when you were were younger and and what
was the moment where you were like okay
I'm nasty at fighting I want you to hold
that thought let's go to Masterworks to
our sponsor we're going to come back to
that question go ahead Rob according to
CNBC the world's richest families in
2023 increased their Network by roughly
$1.5 trillion dollar while many low
middle income regular people are like
that didn't happen to me I'm not
experiencing this and now we're hearing
about the fact that the FED May decrease
the rate six times in 20124 what could
that do to the marketplace does money
become cheap again what do people buy so
if you want to create wealth you almost
have to study they do what the wealthy
many of them invest their money into is
Art so what Masterworks allows you to do
is let's just say we see an Andy warhall
piece art or you know Picasso Bank SE $2
million a million you can't afford to
buy that whole thing maybe you want to
buy a share of it Masterworks allows you
nearly 900,000 people have registered to
buy a share of that art piece and many
of their investors some of your venders
who use it have gotten a return of
nearly $45 million buying art through
Masterworks so if you want to learn more
go to
masterworks.io click on the link
below question Vinnie's asking a
question because I I not everybody gets
bullied but there are some people that
get bullied that get pushed to to to
fight what were you bullied uh Kamar who
was it who was like that main enemy and
then what was the moment in your life
where you're like yo I got I got hands I
can
fight um I wouldn't
say I mean
it's I guess the term bullying and and
what we kind of see that as is you know
just daytoday continuous a kid gets
belittled and things like that I I mean
to to an extent growing
up especially going to public
school well I guess any school you know
there's a little bit of bullying that
that happens
but for me looking back at it it's
almost it's almost kind of character
building you know you're going to have
those kids that are just you know that
are just want to be punks
and so I I had a little share of that
but I wouldn't say I was just Oddball to
the point where you know I I felt like
there had to be something done but I I I
got into a a couple little scraps
um back in in in grade school because
when we immigrated here um I think I
started the school system in fourth
grade Arlington Texas yeah in Arlington
Texas so starting in fourth grade now
kids are know fourth grade kids are
cruel and kids are smart and and you
know I didn't English isn't necessarily
my first language so now you you talk a
little different you have a little bit
of an accent and and kids know you're
not from here and so of course kids kids
poke fun of you and and and do certain
things to kind of make you feel a
certain way so I had a little bit of
that but you know I was always somewhat
able to blend in with the crowd and and
and be okay but I had a couple scraps
growing up gotcha and I didn't really I
wasn't a fighter I didn't really I did
with my brothers I was that's three boys
don't get me we're we're going to scrap
nonstop yeah PB you have to tell your
story
about I understand but go ahead you're
saying especially me and my little
brother we scrapped all the time all the
time what's the age gap between the two
of you we're we're about two and a two
years apart I think he's 34 yeah so
we're all two years apart so yeah that
that we always scrap and I I was just I
something I took from cuz my dad was
kind of a non-nonsense kind of guy and
so I was kind of that way as well
especially with my little brother I I
couldn't deal with him disr being
disrespectful so if he told me to shut
up at any point oh that was disrespect
oh we had to scrap and so we fought for
a long long time by the way I think
that's super healthy it yeah it has to
be F it's not like you have beef with
your brother but like growing up getting
tough knowing when you know stepping on
boundaries you know keeping it real goes
wrong Advantage I think it's an
advantage I think if you're raised with
a young with a brother that's the same
age as you you have an advantage in
school when fights break out because
you're accustomed to fighting 50 100 200
times with your brother and if a boy is
raised with a sister only you don't have
a brother you don't have somebody to
fight so then the first time it happens
it's the first actual fight you're
having so my kids my two boys they're a
year and a half apart uh the other day I
come home and we're packing to go to uh
uh you know AR Christmas they're packing
all this stuff so anyways they find
these uh uh snow uh gloves right you
know so Dylan puts the gloves on he puts
his beanie on they're thinking this is
gear they come into the bedroom and they
start going at it right and then the
first one throws a kick now these guys
have been doing Jiu-Jitsu for 2 and A2
years so the first one throws a kid the
kick and then next thing you know Dylan
throws this vicious kick the whole back
is red the younger kicks the older one
now it's an official brawl okay no it's
a brawl Jennifer comes out what's going
on I said babe this is a good
fight that Pay-Per-View fight you went
to go get a beer and you came back and
it was done this is a good
fight and they're like Dad Dad hey can
we can we get a ring and get other other
people to come and watch us fight I want
others to see us we're not doing that
bro we're not this is not going to be
like he Michael Vick story Patrick B
David sells ticket fights so so so that
part coming up with hold on but then the
end of the story when Dylan kicked you I
thought yeah so then I said Dylan I want
to see how your kick feels oh great line
up I said go kicked the side I just want
to know how it feels it did not feel
good I have to tell you I he's there he
he's going to kick you I want you to
feel it I understand and Kamar the first
time I hung out with them on the boat
he's like yeah go wrestle with Uncle
Vinnie one of them has me in a Choco and
I'm I'm getting there and then the other
one grabs his wrist and is pulling it
and I'm going and I just see him
laughing going like you good and I was
like n they're strong it's about the age
when it gets annoying the next two years
at 14 years old I don't want to get KCK
how are they they they're 10 and 12 10
and 12 10 and 11 10 and 11 yeah and and
they're they're uh uh it's fun when
they're so we f do we do wrestling and
we fight two and one against me I still
have them but it's getting
annoyed it's getting annoyed where you
he might need you to be a tag team over
there against the two boys bro I'll stay
on I'll stay on this side but let's
let's continue so let's talk about this
this recent fight Kobe and and uh uh
Leon that took place you fought Leon a
couple times and maybe we'll come back
to to the fights you've had with Leon
but to me when I'm when I'm hearing what
he's saying you know hey uh the comment
he makes about his father and you know
here's what's going to happen when we're
going to go to hell and you're going to
do this and then Sean Strickland comes
out and Strickland says what he says
about Kobe he had some Choice words I
don't know if you heard what Sean said
about Kobe where is the limit is there a
limit of where you can go will Dana ever
get in and say too leave the wives and
the father and the family alone or in
the fight World there is no
limits well I don't think that's that's
Dana's job you know Dan is a
promoter and so his job is to promote
the fights you know he has a whole
company that he's looking out for and
this is fight Sports I mean it's it's
very difficult to tell two grown men hey
don't say that about this you know I
mean this is not scripted you know this
is as the modotto is is as real as it
gets and
so
obviously you know me being a man that I
am and and growing up the way that I
grew up I understand that there's a
limit to certain things there's certain
boundaries and certain lines that we
just we don't cross and I and I I think
that goes
into just upbringing and and and the
respect factor of just growing up in
life we understand that there's certain
things that that you just don't do just
like you know as I believe in war you
know Wars wage with men men wage Wars
you know it's very difficult
to to start attacking women and children
that just is never been a thing that men
do you know if I have
conflict with that side okay I signed
like when they say sign up for war it's
men that sign up we sign up and we go
defend and so the same thing with with
what we're doing because in in a way
we're Waging War with one another and so
when we do this things you kind of you
know that's that's what men do we leave
those those out because it's between us
we have to step in there and we have to
take care of whatever we say we're going
to
do and so nowadays it's you know we're
we're in this weird times of society to
where it's everybody wants to be seen
everybody wants to be
heard and we're just it's information
overload you know everyone we have these
mics we have these phones we have these
things that just we all want to just be
out there and so people just they're
willing to say or do anything whether
it's men whether it's women willing to
do and say anything just to be seen and
these guys are just kind of being lost
in that to where they just I'm not going
to be seen if I don't say this or cross
that line or do this for me I I just
I've never been that kind of guy and I
guess that's kind of been a knock on
me um some people didn't like the fact
that you know when I'm dominating
everyone I'm not belittling them I'm not
you know saying this or saying that you
know and McGregor was the same way M
McGregor came out well not the same way
as me but when he came out he was doing
the same things he there was in the line
is what you're talking about it wasn't a
yeah there wasn't a line that McGregor
wasn't willing to cross and we saw what
that where that got him you know
McGregor's probably one of the most
famous mixed martial arts fighter ever
no doubt and so by with that you know
you have all these young kids now
looking at that and going oh yeah I can
just say and do whatever I want to do
that's going to make me famous I I think
about this because I I see you know how
the saying Styles makes fights and if
anyone knows this this is your world you
know this you guys understand what it
means when Styles make make fights but
do you think personality self fight so
it is does it kind of go to you know a
Conor comes in I don't remember him
being that loud at the beginning I I
don't know like the first couple of
fights and then all of a sudden he's
like getting louder and louder Lou you
just didn't you know he was loud give a
story give a story behind the scenes
like how loud the light wasn't on you
know oh I got you it's so that's I guess
that's kind of how algorithm of what the
social media is now is you're loud but
if if not enough people are paying
attention right away then it doesn't
seem that loud that's a good point But
as soon as more people are paying
attention what happens more people start
turning they start putting the camera on
you more and more more and more and more
and more so more and more people start
to see you and it starts to grow and
grow and get louder and louder yeah he
was he was he's been that guy he's been
he's been that guy was your first
interaction with him Conor I was
actually I my interaction actually with
him is not been many I don't think have
we had we had a couple but not not many
um I actually was at his first ever UFC
fight first fight first his first ever
UFC fight but I wasn't in the UFC at
that point I was
cornering a uh I was cornering a friend
of mine uh Michael Johnson in Stockholm
Sweden doesn't he live here Michael
Johnson live yeah we had lunch at the
house a month ago real nice guy yeah so
I was Michael Johnson was was fighting
in Stockholm Sweden and I was cornering
him and I was one of his main training
Partners at the time so I'm cornering
Michael Johnson and there's this guy I
didn't really know too many guys on the
card at that time in the UFC but there's
this guy Irish guy but I knew who he was
fighting a kid named Marcus brimage who
had trained with us a little bit and so
they get in the fight and I'm I'm just
like okay I know Marcus brimage I know
he's talented guy very tough guy and
who's this guy's fighting and then
Marcus had told us oh it's this young
guy that they're they're UFC's promoting
they're pushing and this and that and I
never heard of him I'm like oh okay I
see this you know little you know slim
guy there at the time and so they get in
and this this Irish guy and they're
fighting and and I'm like OHA he's not
bad he's actually really good and yeah
and 24 look what he looks like no tto
nothing nothing Slim skinny suck down
145 lbs and goes out there and makes it
look Flawless
and and he's just Brash and he gets on
the mic and he was good on the mic real
good and um I like it's not bad but I
you know I've seen plenty of Fighters
come and go come in hot and go but it's
after that I think maybe one more fight
and then there he had like a whole
series on Fox you know like a two or
three part series on Fox so now we're
starting to see him on this side of the
world and so it just grew and grew and
grew and you know he was just a guy that
was at the right place right time that
knew how to capitalize on the
opportunity and and then have Ireland on
your back one of the like I mean for UFC
to me he was like he just put them on
the on his back and then UFC embedded
and then with um o Aldo and then that
was it bro that was just and Usman
follow up to Pat's question about
personality and Persona so your younger
brother's just getting started in the
UFC right so I mean going to use it as a
case example so in business you have two
major elements right you have the
product then you have the marketing so
your brother's just getting started or
any young fighter that's getting started
how do you balance the product being a
good fighter actually having the skills
with the marketing right like you see
more guy like Patty the baty pimpl
Another Irish guy I mean I can't look
away from that guy right uh Connor for
instance or even Colby right but there's
other guys that are just straight great
products right adna yourself whoever you
want to put nagu what advice would you
give your brother as far as the product
versus the
marketing well I mean it's tough
nowadays it's really tough because this
the lines are
blurred they've been blurred and so I
think all these guys are struggling with
finding an identity or where where they
want to be because you can't your your
your BK can't be louder than your bik
and so that's what you're seeing now
that's what we saw this last weekend you
know it can't be that way with Kobe you
mean yeah you know um
but and I think you know my my my
brother is kind of struggling with that
you know in a bit because I know my
brother I know the things that that make
him great I know the qualities that make
him great make him likable and make him
funny the things that that he
does that make him you know make him
interesting character but him in his
head I don't think he sees it that way
the way that I because I guess they
would say it's in the eye of the
beholder I don't I don't he don't see
himself the way that I see him that that
way I know the world would see him that
makes sense and so he might not
necessarily want to put that side of him
out for the world to see but even though
I think and I know now that that might
equate to dollars he might not agree to
that he might not see it that way and so
especially the camera is a very powerful
thing once the camera is in your face
boom it changes a lot you know people
change some people come on and some
people go on the shell and I I think a
lot of people are struggling with that
especially as Fighters because now not
only you just a fighter you have to be
an Entertainer as well and for me I
think it was a little easier because we
were still growing into this social
media age and to where I just wanted and
for me I didn't care about being famous
when I came in it wasn't about being
famous it was just
about competing being great at something
and of course having a couple dollars in
my pocket who do you think does it the
best meaning has the bark and has the
bite and does it the best today or all
time all time today and all time just
all time has it all the the Showmanship
but also the skills to pay the bill in
mixed martial arts or in just fight
Sports in general in your world in UFC
World in my world I I mean it has to be
it has to be Conor you know
for it has to be Conor because we never
we had never really seen it go to that
level because I mean we we saw a
littleit bit with cha but you know as
much as I love cha there was just
certain cha was just kind of handicapped
in certain ways he wasn't as as
excellent of a striker as certain as
Connor was and at the end of the day
people will love to see you knock
somebody out because that's just as far
as men we that's something that we you
know you have a problem with the
neighbor down the street you wish you
can just walk down there knock him out
so we love to see that and Connor was in
a position where he was doing that he
was able to say I'm Gonna Knock You Out
and goes out there and actually gets a
knockout picks the round too right yeah
and so that that's that was something
that was so appealing by him and he was
just it was great everything was just he
was at the right place right time in in
in society where he had that accent to
that funny little accent to where and we
[__] you up man the the world loves
accents we love it you know and so that
it was just the perfect combination and
at the time where he was really on top I
think you know Conor I would say who's
doing it the best now
honestly I don't know I'm kind of pulled
away you know from that but um if I
would say who's doing it the best
now honestly I I'm going through the
weight
classes I don't know I I I would
say Israel was doing great but you know
it's not he's not necessarily uh
Israel is a showman but it it's it's I
would say I don't know honestly right
now I I don't really know I don't know a
guy that's that's really delivering like
that to say you know what I'm going to
stop this guy this round and this how
I'm going to do it and go out there and
actually risk it and do it because what
we do is so difficult you know it looks
easier on TV but it it's so difficult
once you're in there you realize I'm
really trapped in the cage are there any
guys that you're like Okay so let's just
say Patty or are there anybody where
it's like this guy has has a shot that
guy has a shot or not really anybody
coming up no there's some guys coming up
but that the personality might not be
there yet you know there's
um
[Music]
there's Hamza
chamay I think he plays the role very
very well of you know vill yeah
everyone's just yeah everyone's just you
know scared of his presence of gu he is
no he's a he's a beast yeah um and so so
he he kind of embodies that you know and
and of course he has this accent too and
he comes in I'm going to kill everybody
you know so it's it's kind of you know
appealing to where people want to hear
more so he's he's he's he's a good
really good Fighter um there's a guy uh
that's actually fighting for the
featherweight Championship Ilia Toria
and he's uh I think he's from Spain he's
a Spanish guy but uh good looking kid um
can fight you know can fight can deliver
a great fight standup fight can wrestle
you know decently well he's a mixed
martial artist and I think he has the
potential to be a star because he he he
has all the components good-looking guy
can fight you know the way that people
want to see see him fight so 26 yeah and
um he just has all the component
components to where he could be a star
Oh sha
yeah sugar Shan sugar Shan Ali I think
is uh he's doing a really good job of
just kind of branding and and good he's
a good talker yeah good talker and he
can fight and Adam not to correct but I
I mean I have to you know people are
going to talk crap uh Patty the baddy
he's not Irish he's from England
actually but that accent crazy that
accent you're you don't say just to
throw that out there I know people like
what is he talking about the accent is
so hard [__] you up for what the you
don't know it's different because he's
um I think it's he's it's a SC scer a
crazy it's uh what was the movie snch
for with Brad Pit when you didn't
understand you understand a word he was
saying the guy
Richie he's entertaining as hell bro but
he's doing yeah and he's he just won he
just won he just won yeah he's he's he's
getting there but it's it's um to really
see that Ascension that that Conor got
mhm you got to fight in a particular
certain way you know of course mix Marsh
mix martial arts is still growing it's
still the world doesn't exactly
understand the intricate details of what
we're doing you take a guy down and
you're working for submissions the world
doesn't necessarily understand that the
world still understands two men standing
slugging it out they understand that you
have a problem this is how we we we do
it and so Connor was that guy to where
Connor didn't necessarily want to be
grappling and and doing all that he knew
how to Grapple but he necessarily want
to be there he wanted to throw fisted
cuffs and get you out of there and
that's what I think was what are the
chances he uh he makes a comeback you
see how massive he is I was just going
to say that uh Kamar uh you know he lost
in 2021 he fractured his leg everybody
saw I couldn't even watch it and I mean
if you can't deny it if you see before
and after right now he's thicker like
Adam said his facial structure is
changing I mean I I get it when you're
that rich and you get the top-notch you
know recovery and all that stuff but you
like is is is there any hormone or
growth or something cuz I know you have
to be taking stuff to to heal that bone
and he healed pretty fast you think that
there's anything I don't want to the
thing is I don't want to speculate but I
mean you know when you when you pull
it's kind of difficult when you pull
yourself out of the testing pool and
then you know now I'm going to make a
comeback and you can jump back in you
know it raises a lot of eyebrows but I
don't want to speculate on what he's
doing or not but I I do think if he does
which he will fight I think it seems
like he's going to fight again he does
fight I think you I mean it's it's going
to be big big news it's everyone's going
to watch it because he's just that big
of a star he's gotten himself to that
point do you think he goes with an easy
W or a challenging guy there's that's
the thing with with mixed martial arts
there's no such thing as easy W this is
literally the sport where anything can
happen at any time there's no such thing
as a easy fight you can think this is
easy fight but even the the the guy on
the street has a puncher chance he next
at the right time guess what you're
waking up asking what happened yeah so
there's no such as an easy fight I I for
Connor I just don't
think I I I do think he makes a a
comeback he wins some he might win
fights here and there you know but I I
just don't see him becoming a champion
again because it's a different mindset
to be there
and it's very very tough to plug in to
that and was was he supposed was a fight
him and Chandler were building up
weren't they come on they and that's why
though is it because the power of broke
when you're hungry coming up you're
salivating in getting your shot and then
when you make a few hundred million
dollars the the the the fire to want to
get up early train the distractions I
got to go do a photo shoot I got to go
have dinner with this guy I got to go do
this celebrities are calling to get away
and at the beginning no celebrities
calling you just kind of like you you
have plenty of time to train yeah I I
it's all of that it's mination of all of
that and what it boils down to is is the
commitment that it
takes um when you're on the way up you
there's only one direction you're
looking and that's just where I want to
get to if your goal is I want to make a
million dollars and that's all you're
focused on and in order for me to get
there I need I need that belt I need
that belt I need that belt that's all
you think about that's all you focus
about so subconsciously it just becomes
your whole
that's what you're fixated on that's
where you're going that's where you're
going and you could have bumps in the
road things that kind of you know slow
you down but you're looking one way the
whole time you're plugged in you know
the light might dim here and there but
you're plugged in the whole time and
you're getting up there but when you get
there now different things that you
didn't expect responsibilities are there
because all on the right up all you have
is time to train no one's calling you no
one's you know you don't have to go New
York and and promote this fight or do
this and that and you're there for 2
three days which that's 2 three days out
of training so all you're doing is
you're doing all these things and you
don't realize you truly separating
yourself from the pack cuz you're so
plugged in with what you're doing but
then once you get
there those two three days were two
three days that when you put in you know
and your your mind knows in the back of
your head I put those extra two three
days in these guys can't touch me I'm
better than everybody it subconsciously
creates that identity and so when you
don't have that or you're pulled this
way and that way and this way and that
way the world is catching up because
everyone there's guys that are looking
up to that position and they're coming
up they're still moving but now your
your progression is not as fast as it
was it's it's slowly starting to dim
down so they're starting to catch up a
little bit and catch up a little bit but
then boom something happens and when
you're up there the only way to go is
you go down a bit and now having to plug
back in that's the conflict because now
you know what it took to get there you
know the level of commitment that that
was you knew that you were getting up to
6:00 a.m. running extra when you didn't
really need to and you didn't have to
but you just on the right up you were
just like yeah this might help me I'm
going to do it cuz it might help me but
now you just woke up and silk sheets
you're like you know
what I'm good I'm good I'm just going to
go to the 10: a.m. training that's
that's good I don't need to run at 6:
a.m. I'll go to 10: a.m. training so
when you're doing all
that you know everyone's starting to
catch up now it makes it difficult like
do I plug back in how do I can I plug
back in so that decision to plug back in
to be able to get back up there that's
very difficult to do when you don't have
those you know you're not
hungry you know you had steak last night
you know then what do you
what do I want to eat
tomorrow I can eat anything I want right
or when you didn't have it it's like I
would love steak and surf and turf
you're eating ramen noodles at that
point you're hungry it's like so the
decision to be able to plug back in I
think is GNA be I think he's B I don't
think I know he's battling with like how
do I become that guy again how how
important his age cuz you guys are
pretty similar age I think he's one year
uh younger than you you're 36 he's 35
yeah how much much does age and we've
seen Tom Brady playing at least 45 we
see 40s not LeBron's about to be 40 the
the 40 number isn't as big of a deal as
it was a couple Generations ago or even
last generation you're 35 he's 36 how
much do age play a factor in that
comeback so to speak oh definitely play
a factor I mean we're not Tom Brady
we're not we don't have
350lb guys protecting us and we're just
throwing a ball you know um not to say
that that's not hard that's extremely
difficult and I mean what Tom Brady's
done he's IQ being able to break down
defenses and and you know he's he's a
goat in his right in his
sport but we are literally breaking our
bodies all day every day and you know
yes the the world only gets to see us
for that 25 minutes while we're up there
but they don't see the five months that
we put in to get there that's even more
difficult that 25 minutes is just the
fun part you know that's the fun part
that you guys just get to see that's not
what kills us that's not what breaks our
bodies it's the months and months and
weeks and weeks of practice that we're
putting in twice a day sometime some
guys are getting it three a days you're
lifting you're grappling and you're
sparring and you're doing this so it's
all of
that at the end of the day the one thing
that doesn't change
is evolution is what we're it's not just
Evolution it's time as a human being
this is what is has been created is
you're born you age and then your body
deteriorates and you pass that's going
to happen that hasn't stopped that's not
going to stop until we I mean unless
someone creates a magical pill that just
stops all of that but yeah age plays a
factor what Rogan said about your body
was wild I'm sure you heard what he had
to say famously he's like dude this
guy's absolute Savage he's a beast but
his knees are all messed up he has to
walk on the grass not the sidewalk
sometimes times you have to walk
downstairs backwards is what all Rogan
said but he goes It's all about his
mindset physically he's messed up but
mentally he's Top Notch how do you how
does that all work yeah I mean I did
that for years it it was funny I was
like man I've been doing this for years
I was walking down backwards for to
where I can close my eyes in the middle
of the night dark and just walk
downstairs backwards without grabbing
the rail like Moon walking Michael
Jackson out here I got so good at
because of the pain it was initially was
because I I was just like you know what
let me try this cuz I had um I had a
micr fracture surgery in
2015 and that's because I had no
cartilage in in that knee and it was
just they were bone on bone and it just
created so much arthritis and just it
was just so painful just walking and I
just always felt like it was just loose
bodies and things in there and so I was
like let me try going down backwards one
day and I went and it just kind of
relieved the the pain of you know coming
down like oh start trying that so I just
started doing that everywhere and it
just became part of my day walking back
the I'm just backwards coming downstairs
backwards but I think last year I
started coming back I started walking
nor normally again because I I realized
that what it did over time cuz when you
come down the stairs a certain way or go
up the stairs a certain way it does
build muscle in a certain way it builds
your legs in in a certain back training
going back safety it builds it builds a
a different type of conditioning and I
was just like wait I have I've been
doing this for years now maybe we maybe
that didn't you know do wasn't the
greatest thing for me and so now but the
pain level is not where it used to be
anymore you know I've done a couple of
stem cells and it's helped quite a bit
let me let me ask this when I when I
look at um like in the business world
yeah when you lose it's not uh um
business in entrepreneurship you lose
every day you lose clients you lose
employees you lose best salespeople you
lose contracts you lose uh Capital you
were raising you uh your company goes
out of business there's many things
you're constantly losing but it's not on
pay-per-view with tens of millions of
people watching you when you're losing
because you lose people in the company
know competitors know industry knows but
it's not on the paper the next day with
you know viral Clips going off it's got
few hundred million views and everyone's
watching it
right for you when I look at the list of
fights you had you beat Edwards uh
you've uh uh beat Kobe I think you beat
him twice right did you yeah you beat
him twice Gilbert Burns which by the way
to me I don't know how much credit
Gilbert Burns get he's he's a dog of a
fighter so this is this is not an easy
fight to beat him you beat him um you
beat mazal uh uh I think also twice yeah
you beat him twice obviously you have
that One Clip where everyone's seen and
we're sitting there and I'm saying you
know mazal is about to get him and I'm
on the other side I'm like he's about to
get him and then we're sitting with
friends are like damn bad he got mvol
and then you and everybody's like what
the hell just happened made no sense
that knockout may be one of the wildest
Knockouts in in UFC and then who am I
missing you um oh Tyrone Woodley which
by the way at one point he was a guy
that could gone up and you know maybe
Dana didn't like the fact that he wasn't
a showman and he would fight Point
fights you beat him and then Edwards
quite guy guy you beat before he catches
you in the fifth round with whatever a
minute left and then another one and
then com out the last fight that you had
I think you only had two weeks and he
didn't knock you out and went five
rounds that was a you know decision that
that was made how do you go from the
high of you know one of the most viral
Knockouts of all time against Mazel you
beat Kobe back to back in that one
conference where he's sitting there you
guys are talking [__] you're dressed in
a suit I believe I think you were
dressed in a suit and you professionally
talking and he's just calling you out
calling you out let's go let's go right
now well let's go right now and then it
goes to this how do you manage the super
super high to the super low in your
world that's that's a good question it's
a very it's a very tough thing to be
able to do
because um you don't really plan for
that
no one plans for that like I said when
you're when you're going a certain way
you only look one way and that's up
you're just looking up up up up up and
no one thinks about what if I go down
and that's what they tell you you don't
you don't think about the negatives or
what could happen you're just you're
supposed to be just focused on this part
but no one really teaches you how to
deal with with that so I think for me
the big the big advantage that I had is
I was never really attached to that I
didn't get into the sport saying man I
want to be famous or I want to be want
everyone to see me I got into this going
man I really love to compete and show
like what I've been working on the
skills and things that I I want to best
that other man I want to be in that
competition I want to be the best in
that competition that was really what I
was attached to
and making money of course I mean I
wanted to be able to provide for my
family and and support them
so that was what I was attached to too
so you know being once I I got there I
didn't necessarily you know was like oh
man I love this I love being famous I
didn't necessarily care about that I
still don't care it still kind of makes
me feel a certain way when when people
kind of run up and and you know want
pictures or autograph you know even
though I've grown into the role it still
kind of is a little cuz deep down inside
in my mind it's like people want
pictures and autographs of me you know
you're still that kid in in the back of
your mind mind
but it's a difficult place to be because
there's a lot of depression that comes
with that because once you're you're for
me I would say that part is
from like I mentioned wanting to be the
best at it I want to be known as the
best because I put the time and the work
in to be the best and so when that's not
the case you're not being recognized as
that there is that that the impression
that comes with that but over time I I I
learned kind of how to you know tools to
deal with that and of course having a
good support system around you what is
that what's what are those tools the
systems well first and foremost is
acknowledging and understanding that
it's going to happen whether you win
it's going to happen even the most V the
The massal
Knockouts you're on this High man a week
two weeks three weeks then it's Fizzles
out and you're at home it's just like
what's
next and then you kind of you come down
from that and then there's depression
that comes with it and you have to be
able to know how to recognize that
acknowledge it and and be able to okay
this is the things that I do to be able
to help me get back out there or get my
mind off of this or or pivot and for me
you know my family of course is some
some Fighters don't have that to where
so them so when it's just you that's a
very difficult thing to be able to deal
with but for me I have a child you know
she comes in the room and she wants to
play you got to play because and and
what you're not realizing is that gets
you away from from just sitting there
drowning in your your sorrow it's like
man I just lost this fight or or what am
I doing today what do I do next week so
my family is is my support system and
how I deal with that but definitely
understanding cuz some guys don't
understand why do I feel the need to go
to go outside why do I feel the need to
do this why do I feel the need that I
just I'm just inside and I'm sad for
what for what reason so there's a lot of
that that comes with it but you know
it's you know I'm kind of in that place
now where
it's you know I've always been had these
Crossroads kind of in my
career you know I have a Crossroads do
you pivot or do you do something do you
do you double down on this do you pivot
do you double down on this and now
obviously getting into the business
world too is is trying to understand
that because it it's very difficult you
touched on something you know business
in business you're losing every day but
there's not that magnifying glass that
scope on it for the world to see and
which makes it very very difficult
because now starting to get into the
business world it's like I'm starting to
understand that and I'm not all the way
in in there yet so you know it's been
difficult but it's you know it's
learning how do you learn what do you
read who do you listen to how do you get
better of business well that's that's
something that I I I'm still working on
I'm working on there I do you know
listen look at you know a few guys um
but I mean the best teacher is is
experience I mean is experience you know
if you never experience it it's very
difficult to just listen to everybody
cuz what worked for that guy might not
be what works for you and so you know
just just going off of what someone has
done obviously that's a good road map
but I guess experience getting in there
and understanding wow okay I did that
that wasn't great don't do that again M
that I think that's the best teacher
it's kind of like with fighting like you
can watch the videotapes and read all
the books and have a trainer but unless
you get in the gym and see what it it
feels like to get punched in the face
you're never going to no book's going to
tell you what it's like to get punch
punch in the face very true but uh I
mean obviously there's there's coaching
that's involved in everything if you
want to be the best you know cuz a coach
might be able to teach you skills that
you don't necessarily know so yeah I'm
I'm I'm definitely in that position I
have a few people around that uh and now
that's the the the good thing now is you
have access you know I I guess that's
what the the popularity kind of buys you
is is a little bit of access to be able
to be around great people and great man
that can teach you some of those things
but yeah I've I've you know business is
not as easy who's the who's the wildest
person where you know when you're
winning because in in the content World
you'll make a piece of content and then
eventually some of the stuff goes viral
and then someone will DM you and they'll
say hey man I just want to let you know
I don't say this publicly but I follow
your content your stuff is good right oh
where you follow the [__] that's great
and our first time it happens it's a
real you know unique experience for a
content Creator uh but but for you as a
fighter when you started coming up and
then all of a sudden winning and then
dominating and then pound for pound
number one the talks possibly the top
five greatest of all time this was the
conversation just a year and a half ago
it's not like we're talking 10 years ago
right so when conversations like that
happen goats are attracted to goats so
who were some goats that reached out to
you called you out of nowhere you know
or ran into you or wanted to have dinner
with you where like dude I'm having
dinner with this guy this is pretty wild
what was that moment for
you it's been a lot I mean and it's
still happening you know I I I I guess
you don't know your your reach because
it's not yeah we're connected we're all
connected now but they say there's
there's there's kind of there's a reason
why you know um like let's say Instagram
for for example there's a reason why the
picture that you post said you know my
your your story might have more more
eyes than the actual people that liked
your picture that you posted you know
more people are watching than you
actually do know and
so I've I mean I'll run into people and
they're just
like you know I'm I'm I'm a fan these
are people that I've watched or grew up
watching I'm a fan of and I you know say
hi and they're like oh yeah we know know
who you are and it's like oh really you
know me you know you know I've had that
moment a few times what was the first
one though what was the first one cuz
that's the one that's a it's it's
different once you experience it I guess
it's diff it's I guess it's different
level of of what celebrities are and
there's been some there's been some some
some big ones and I I I guess at the
time some might be you know huge to me
and then you get to a certain level and
they get really really big I mean
I've Shaq I mean me and Shaq are pretty
cool you know we've we've you know been
around each other quite a few times um
Shaq is cool and I think you know
spending time getting to know him a
little bit you you you realize okay
super likable guy that's that's a cool
guy that's a guy I could hang around
with for a whole week and just be cool
um being meeting Tom Brady when it's
actually funny how Tom Brady and I kind
of uh uh so Tom Brady's uh is's a fight
fan he comes to fights sometimes and um
um he um he was at my fight in I think
he's been at a couple of my fights but
the one that I remember was he's at my
fight in Jacksonville with the masol the
second fight and so after that I mean
that fight because it was the first I
believe the first sporting event back
with a live audience in the world and so
after that fight I'm in the back and
just you know there doing the back of
house stuff media and and all of this
and that night was probably one of the
most memorable nights that I I've had
because just seeing my family around
back it was the first fight my father
got to attend live and so having just
everyone there it was just having a
great time and my daughter was awake and
she was just loving it
and I just you know remember I'm I'm
talking to her and she comes to the back
and we're we're talking and she's having
a great time and and she's like oh man I
had to I asked her if you had a great
time she's like yeah I'm having a great
time and she told me yeah I was taking a
lot of pictures I was like oh that's
cool you know because that's the thing
is I just she's always been around me
all the time and so she goes yeah I was
take a picture with this baseball player
and uh and this other guy I was like oh
there baseball player she's like yeah I
took a picture with him and and she's
like oh my chave took a picture with
with him so I'm like oh okay cool so I
didn't really pay any attention at all
baseball player you know I knew a few I
knew a few baseball players I mean which
I love baseball and I KN I knew a few
baseball players at the time um so I'm
just thinking oh baseball there's a lot
of celebrities out there so you know a
baseball player so I'm like oh cool so
then I get the
picture later
on it's
Tom it's a big of uh it's on it's on her
IG uh um U Miss pretty 2014 and I and I
see the picture and I'm like
um wait no this can't be the baseball
player so cuz the her aunt sent me the
picture so I uh that she's she's in bed
and so I um I wait for her to wake up
the next day I'm
like is this the baseball player she
goes yeah yeah that's him I'm like
really that's that's the baseball player
Tom Brady she's like yeah and so um when
I actually went to uh the game that New
Orleans versus uh uh and Tampa that's
when uh you know I met Tom again and uh
we actually got chance right there we
got chance to actually speak and and
catch up and he's like oh hey how are
you how's your daughter and I'm like
how's your daughter like my daughter
she's fine cuz how's your baseball game
when the game baseball player I told him
the story but I'm not sure I'm like you
would believe what she did that's a
great so
funny yeah so I mean Tom Brady I'm it's
been a ton of other guys like actors
musicians a lot of lot of
musicians um because I'm I'm I love
music you know and so right now uh uh
Toby and wigway good friend of mine and
uh he's just a rising artist and the one
thing that I just like my he's like a
brother to me and the one thing that I
just love about him is he's so authentic
to who he is he's a family man and he
takes his family everywhere and I'm just
like man I would love that luxury to be
able to just take them at whatever I'm
doing they're there front and center his
kids are getting a front row seat of
seeing what Mommy and Daddy does on a
daily basis and not that they're missing
out they have tutors and they have
babysitters with them that's family
members with them all the time and I'm
just watching I'm just like man how
great is this because we don't see this
anymore you know people don't get that
especially not kids nowadays they don't
get to see that and and just watching
him walk and ascending what he's doing
is just it's
amazing that's cool with the you know
the the stories of who you meet I
remember Tom was at the event with us
and my son the youngest son Dylan is
like you know I want to catch a ball
from you and Tom's like what are we
waiting for let's go right now and he
was just such a gamer like he just
wanted to go out there and you know uh
you you would think from one end this
guy's the greatest to ever lace him up
in football but on the other end this
guy's just the regular guy who you know
wants to compete and play the game as
much as the other guy does so Pat you
you also went across the middle from Tom
Brady you one in dress shoes I mean at
the ball come on you caught that ball no
one called me for a contract though I
was disappointed may could have been you
Syrian assassin assassin sounds Syrian
assassin so go going back to going back
to UFC and you know with with these
fights that are taking place
so Jake Paul uh uh has this fight with
this guy I don't you know Andre August
right and then George jenko Goes and
flies out to Romania and uh he sits down
with uh Andrew Tate and they have this
interview right and the interview does
very very well George is a phenomenal
interview a Syrian guy um we make the
introduction they go they have a great
time Andrew is like absolutely i' love
to sit down with them and the interview
was he's by the way he's actually phen I
don't know if you saw it or not he's a
phenomenal interviewer but it leads to
this conversation about the Tate
Brothers finding fighting Jake and Logan
Paul I just want to play this to you get
get a reaction to see if you have any
reaction this is George asking Andrew
and will play the video from Logan Paul
giving his thoughts go forward okay two
brothers one cage Jake Logan You Tristan
who comes out alive you know what I'm
trying so hard to not start internet
beats I'm I'm I'm really trying not to
I'm I'm you could say Jake and Logan man
don't worry about it no I can't
lie I'm going through life I'm trying to
live peaceful now I've got fed agents in
my house Matrix is after me I'm just
trying to live peaceful but of course I
have absolute faith in myself and my
brother and I know what we've been
through and I know the kind of men we
are so now play play the clip from play
the clip from uh what what Logan says go
for it that's that's delusion that's
delusion I'm sorry look Andrew fighter
legitimate badass [__] strong
mentality I'm sorry Tristan Tay is a
weak link I say he got he got a bad
shoulder he he's shaped like a
gingerbread man I don't want no beef but
but that's illusion PFO will set this up
uhoh a a MMA
10 million for everybody you might have
a you might have a fight on your hand
that would go crazy let's do it no
seriously about action like I'm not I'm
less talk now that like let's just
[__] go y but you know for a fact me
and Jake will travel to Romania we will
make this happen we'll do it wherever
you want whatever conditions you want
that's that okay so obviously we talked
earlier about who are good talkers and
personality and [__] talkers all that
stuff I mean Jake is fighting making 10
million 20 million a fight that he's
setting up right they're making all this
money with all these fights what what do
you think about the idea of you know
Jake and Logan Paul fighting Andrew and
Tristan
Tate I mean I what what are what kind of
fight what are they doing exactly is it
boxing or is it MMA you know if it's if
it's an MMA fight I think that favors
Jake and Logan it favors if it's MMA for
sure Jake and Logan for sure wait Jake
and Logan yeah Paul the favors them why
would you say I mean they actually
wrestled you know yeah but these guys
got the kicks man they're kick boxers
yeah that that's actually a disadvantage
when it comes to wrestlers you know if I
catch a kick and you fall down like it's
it's different and it's a different
balance when you're a kickboxer you have
to be a little bit more upright because
you have to be able to check kicks and
and stuff when you're boxer you have to
be a little bit more uh split St because
you have to give half your body so it's
different styles but once you get that
takedown a kickboxer or a boxer has no
see people don't realize that the
regular human don't realize just the
regular regular just I guess I would
Sayan the civilian human doesn't
realize that it's an actual skill to be
able to get off of your back yeah as a
man can you imagine being held on your
back and someone just tells you get out
get off your back and you can't do
it yeah think about that yeah it sucks I
could hold somebody on their back for a
day or two if I wanted to you just you
are just on your back you want you want
to give it a shot I can feed you grapes
if I if I if I and bathroom break your
back yeah and there's nothing you can do
about it like that's are you saying
wrestling is the most important thing
just grapping in mixed martial arts 100%
it's grapp that grapp 100% because the
thing is if you think about a
fight there's only three places a fight
can take there's three positions to a
fight think about it we're both standing
up trading punches that's one that's a
neutral position we're both standing up
two I can be on my back you're on top of
me Landing punches or I can be on top of
you on your back Landing punches so 67%
of a fight takes place on the ground now
as a wrestler my discipline is being
able to control which Real Estate take
that fight is taking place so I'm I'm
well versed at being down there so 67%
of I'm is a chance that I'm going to win
this fight and then there's a 33% chance
that in a neutral position anything can
happen so think about that most people
don't think about that like I've won
two-thirds of a fight I've won already
because of being a wrestler to just a
normal person who knows how to throw
hands and so if I'm well versed in that
place I can take you down there or I
have the ability to stop you from taking
me down there
so it's yeah if you if you can wrestle
that that's one of the most important
aspects of of being able to defend
yourself so so in high school you were
what 55 and three or some some record no
it was definitely more than that but
it's uh I think that was my senior year
my senior season and is that why you're
saying is that why you're saying that
the Paul brothers having the wrestling
background that's that big of an
advantage so it's an advantage I mean
obviously it's declined because they
haven't been wrestling
continuously wrestled he doing his WWE
thing yeah but that's different
wrestling that's so funny just saying
he's
sh stop breaking news you're saying that
WWE isn't real yeah Rob don't start
crying I I didn't say that I didn't say
that but real quick I want to know how
how important size is because I got to
stand up for my guy Tristan because I
actually asked Tristan that exact same
question when we were in Romania I asked
literally the same question George jenko
asked I said you and Andrew walk in the
room Logan um and the the Paul Brothers
I said who walks out of life he's like
come on I don't want to play this
juvenile game but come on yeah but my
point is this Tristan is bigger than any
of those guys Tristan's a legit 64 big
yeah no size size is important for sure
but listen don't get me wrong I'm not
saying Tristan doesn't stand a like
that's no absolutely no I'm not saying
that like if this is just a fight yeah
they def defitely have a a good chance I
would say
probably I would have said Andrew Tate
probably is the the more you know
versatile one the most skilled one out
of all of them but you know Jake is
definitely and you can I can just tell
from that interview you can see the
brothers and you see the difference is
Jake is starting to turn
into the athlete the competitor
initially he wasn't like that it was it
was just entertainment purposes he was
hand I mean still handpicking guys and
and you know to test himself but that's
boxing you know you got to get your
bearings before you jump into world
championship fights so you know more
power to what he's doing but he's
handpicking fights but he's starting to
turn into an athlete and you could see
it just from sitting there when you're
when you're an athlete and you're
climbing you start to get this chip on
your shoulder and you see the difference
between him and Logan Logan is is more
of the business guy and Logan's
obviously a little bit more mature a
little bit older to where he's more
relaxed in his answers to where Jake is
kind of the chip on his shoulder that we
can do it right now I'm about to action
you know you can see that in them so
he's starting to become the athlet
what's what's Jake's upside if he
continues down this path and he's not
doing sort of puff pieces and all that
and he's actually fighting in the boxing
world yeah right cuz he fought uh Tyson
Fury's brother Tommy Fury didn't work
out he lost that was the first like but
he had a good fight yeah it was a good
fight no doubt but he lost yeah he
wasn't he wasn't stopped I mean wasn't
like uh just being outclass in any way
no it it was close and I think at one
point he he knocked Tom down but but
what's his upside if he continues down
this path he's pretty young what is he
26 no I mean the guy's the limit you
know he continued to do his thing the
sky's the limit you know what he's being
able to do to blend what he he's doing
blending both the entertainment aspect
of it and still be able to compete is is
you know is I I guess I don't want to
say he's one of the first to do it but
at this level MH you know and and in the
beginning stages when you're zero and
zero and then your first fight and and
or your second fight and you're getting
these many eyeballs and and the internet
to watch this I mean it it's I mean it's
great speaking of the internet would
this be the biggest fight of all time
most viewed fight of all time the Tates
versus the Pauls do you don't think that
they would get eyeballs it was in a cage
you don't think so all
right guys this is the attention economy
the eyeball economy you don't think that
would be a top five top 10 fight okay
depends on what you eyeballs all time
eyeballs that's what I'm saying eyeballs
listen I I guess you know for
entertainment aspect because the world
now is just so polluted with what we
call entertainment like it's you know
the world isn't really we just it's just
want to be entertained by junk and it's
junk junk sells more than actual reality
until the world gets real and now let's
be honest when uh uh Mayweather wanted
to fight Manny Pacquiao
that's the world recognizing that these
are the two of the best athletes in
their respective Fields doing this this
is something special that we have to
watch and you saw what that did that
broke all records but then you you get a
you know you get another piece like
Mayweather and McGregor where it's the
two of the best in their respect
respective sports but you know yeah
we're curious we just want to see what
this looks like so the world Tunes in
but I mean you just get guys that just
fight fighting for the heck of it and
like let's just you know lock the tape
Brothers in a room for these guys I mean
they not that they're not the best in
their respective Fields but no but they
they're the best at getting eyeballs is
my point yeah but but but I but my thing
is how many how many eyeballs did uh way
Mayweather maya8 $280 million on the
fight and McGregor made 130 but like but
but but at the end of the day Kamar it's
like like all respect when people like
no you a hater I'm not a hater Logan and
Jake Paul started on Vine there're
social media gu all right don't you
think like to me this is me it lessens
the Integrity of the sport of boxing
it's like okay I get it that you know
Jake is getting better and he's coming
up a bro and the fury guys whatever he
ain't fighting a real professional boxer
that would be a a completely different
thing and my question to you is come
like their fight like they would never
go MMA like an actual professional
they're fighting these people that if
you you think Jake or Logan Paul he's
saying is if they go MMA they have the
advantage no I'm saying in I'm saying in
general cuz they're not who's the who's
the biggest guy Jake Paul's fought like
I
meanwe just so you know what he's saying
is there is no case study to see who
Jake Paul has fought in MMA because Jake
is only box right yeah I think the the
the biggest thing is is Andrew and and
uh Tristan they're they're conditioning
they're not going to be in the same
conditioning as Logan and Jakob because
Logan and Jake are like in their 20s
going running the amount of distractions
Andrew and Tristan have had right now
like there's no way you you you set up
that fight if you need payday they don't
need to make money they're they're okay
when it comes on to that side but it
would get a lot of eyeballs I would have
liked to have seen him Peak to Peak
competing to see what that looks like
but us kamaru is clearly saying he's not
saying if they do boxing Jake and Logan
have the advantage he's saying if they
do mixed martial arts they have an
advantage due to their wrestling
abilities that would be very interesting
exactly I mean just if it's let's just
say a fight you know there's no rules
out there if we're in the street it's a
fight you know obviously without weapons
yeah we're in a street to fight yeah
obviously Jake and you look at a street
fight most cases where is z going end
yeah two guys rolling on the ground okay
you know so if Jake and and and Logan
and Logan have actually been trained at
some point and how to take the fight
down there or how to get up from there I
mean you don't think they have the
advantage when if a fight breaks out
they 100% do and now and now they also
have trained to stand and throw punches
as well you know which before you would
give that advantage to you know um
Andrew Andrew tapate because he you know
had been kickboxing for a while but you
know that's a a fight yeah they have
that advantage in that realm but I'm
just and say it I'm rooting for the
Tates guys that's it I want to see this
I'm not I'm not saying I'm rooting for
this guy or that guy but I'm just being
I'm just giving you the the facts here
like they would cuz they know how okay
if I grab this leg I run him this way
he's going to fall down or if I run him
that way the balance you know I I
compromise the balance and I get him
down there so yeah it's that's a skill
in itself being able to know that it's
it's different if Andrew Tate was to
grab a leg I'm not I don't know if he
trained wrestling you know but
if he hasn't trained wrestling it's a
lot different yeah do do you guys think
here's my thing the Tates aside do you
think that they would ever I'm talking
about the Logan uh Brothers they would
uh transition yeah whatever I I they
trans like for instance like Woodley
went from he's an MMA guy but he boxed
what's his name uh one of the Jake Paul
do you think heed out what I'm saying is
I I do not think they would last 2
minutes in a ring with like a MMA guy
that's no hes barred fight like a real
fight box he F Woodley he's fought
Woodley so what I'm saying is but but
what I'm saying if Woodley fought uh
Logan Paul and it was an MMA like UFC
type fight who wins that fight oh come
on bro I mean it it's depending on what
you know depending on time you don't
think Woodley would absolutely destroy
any of the
destroy I don't want to say destroy I do
think Woodley winds for sure but I don't
want to say destroy in an MMA fight I
mean the fight starts the fight
starts throwing hands oh man and you
know they've competed against each other
throwing hands and we saw how that went
and so I wouldn't say oh he would
destroy him I do give Woodley the upper
hand because Woodley is a better
wrestler than them uh at least Accolade
wise um but it's a different it's a
different game now I think and then also
you got to account for how much time are
we giving them to train are we giving
him a whole year and a half or two years
to train for this you know because that
definitely makes you know it definitely
makes things a little bit interesting
but I wouldn't say that they would never
go into MMA because I think they're
young enough and and smart enough
business-wise to where they understand
if I'm going to make x amount of dollars
why not FTM follow the money would you
ever participate in something like that
like in the future doing like a boxing
exhibition or not is it called an
exhibition or is an act exhib I mean
yeah exhibition against some fight yeah
I wouldn't mind yeah I wouldn't mind I
you know not too long ago I you heard
here first not to long ago I was crazy
enough to where I I really that's the
thing I was in in my mind I was going to
get Canelo I wanted really really I
wanted Canelo so bad damn 2021 I wanted
him so bad you know it's it's this thing
there's just this Aura of invincibility
that you when you when you are an
athlete and you put so much time
in nothing can stop you you you are
literally uh just a shield nothing can
stop you and I wanted Canelo bad oh that
would have been SI and I I I was I was
like man you know so you saw what
Francis and and Tyson Fury I was on that
level of of belief if not more you know
I wanted
Canelo and boxing straight up yeah all
that' be sick I mean not why not how do
you think you would have done against
Canelo Prime his prime yeah I think uh I
would have given him hell for the first
four rounds for sure I think I would
have given him hell but then after
four let's be real here these guys
that's what he does these guys do this
and it's his skill in itself like and
you watch guys shadow box you know and
and it looks silly all these guys are
just punching air but people don't
realize how hard that is to do
you just do that and these guys are it's
a skill to be able to do it for 12
rounds right 13 20 however many rounds
they choose to do that just to be able
to have the level of just focus just to
be able to just sit there and punch air
and imagine someone in front of you it's
a skill and you know and they just have
the timing they they they see punches
they know the sequence of punches if
you're going to throw you're going to
hit them with the jab jab right hand
they know a left hook is coming they
know to roll they know to do that like
it's just Mastery that they learn and so
for the first four rounds it's going to
be a little confusing because my
sequence is going to be a lot different
than most boxers you know boxers can
throw five six punch combinations you
know I might hit him with two he might
be expecting more no it's not coming and
then another one comes at you know so
it's going to take him time to be able
to compute what's going on but after
four I can't promise what's going to
happen but by the way I'm not going to
lie that Mayweather counter
fight was comp it was actually really
got hands I was very impressed with that
fight and it wasn't a waste of a you're
like what a waste of money for this
fight I was actually entertained yeah I
was actually entertained Francis against
Fury who do you think
won this is your brother so this is this
is I I me cuz I I mean I'm I'm you know
I I'm I'm have to be honest with
everything when it comes to the the the
way that boxing is scored now you of
course they're going to give it to fury
because it's it's just I'm going to
throw pity P even though the punches
don't land I'm hitting it looks like I
have the activity and I'm moving my I'm
just moving around moving around dancing
around piep it looks like I have
activity so they're going to give him
the fight just based on that but if
you're going to say this was a fight who
won this fight there's no doubt Francis
and G won that fight you know he hit him
he dropped him the more effective
punches came from Francis when Francis
hit Fury Fury turned into a Point
fighter and this is Tyson Fury the best
that we that people are saying the best
ever yeah which I I don't think he's the
best ever but I do think he's definitely
in that top five for sure but I don't
think he's the best heavy winner who do
you have in your top five top five
you you got to put Lennox Lewis up there
you put Lennox on absolutely absolutely
Lennox Lewis one of the most effective
heavyweights you've ever seen like you
can get past his jab and then you cann't
get he had the power he had footw work
and he had the tenacity to go out and
get you out of there 100% I put Ln Lewis
up there I mean Evander Holyfield was a
was a was a he was a fighter yeah that
Evander Holyfield I think he wasn't
necessarily the biggest guy but you know
that's where heavyweights were really
fighting you know they weren't throwing
25 punches around these heavyweights
were throwing 60 70 punches around so so
far you got lenck you got Fury and you
got is Mike up there I Evander I yeah
for sure I put Mike up
there uh
because Mike Mike embodied everything
that that a fighter was you know he was
scary before he was scary during he was
scary after eat your kid and that that's
that's uh that's part of that's Art of
War it's part of fighting is you have to
be able to evoke those emotions out of
your opponents you put Lennox ahead of
Frasier you put Lennox ahead of Frasier
when you put al Five I put
um Lennox top five is the that threw me
off yeah I put uh I put uh I put Lennox
definitely yeah I put him so Ali's in
your
five I put Ali in there because he he he
revolutionized the Fraser outside of
five I mean I would put him yeah just
outside of my top five I mean if you got
if you've got you've got you got if
you've got Lennox Holyfield Tyson
Fury Ali you're just talking
heavyweights right now right heavy
because you know Rocky mon yeah just
heavyweight totally get it yeah I mean
and then you you you've got guys like
you've got um um what's uh big guy uh
George Foreman George Foreman yeah
you've got um you've got Larry Holmes
you've
got I mean there's there's some there's
some real Joe Frasier you've got I mean
there's some real real guys but let me
ask you a question about Tyson Fury back
to him and and I say this with ultimate
respect I think he's a beast you're one
of the literally physically impressive
guys out there you're chiseled you're
ripped it's ridiculous bro when you look
at Tyson he's it's I mean I was watching
what makes it I think that's what makes
him is that what it is I was watching a
fight with a girl nanu versus Tyson I go
just look at these guys before the fight
she goes oh the black guy's going to
kick his ass like who's this poy potato
out here I go wait till you see who wins
the fight right and I cuz I knew Tyson
was likely going to win but the fact
that he's just not even in shape talking
about Look At Tyson's Fury sixpack look
at that he never had a six you talking
about he's a beast he's a Savage he's
amazing but how does he not even have
like the shape what's going on it's not
it's not you know fighting is not
necessarily about that not just martial
arts it's not necessarily about the
physique you know there there's there's
some guys that are with with kind of
what I thought it was there and and
that's what adds to Tyson Fury's Story I
mean it's it's the fact that yeah he
he's Pro you don't have to look like a
Francis enanu who is is is just like a
built like a
machine and to to still be able to Excel
and to fight the way he does and even in
in you see it in Jiu-Jitsu you said your
kids do Jiu-Jitsu I mean it's not
necessarily the biggest strongest you
know meanest looking guy out there that
wins you know you can have a little
bitty scrawny guy just basically run
circles around yeah likeo Gracie that
guy was choking people out with their
Gees choking guys out so our ABS just
for show no I mean of course not but
Adam come on but it's good they look
good that's what I'm
saying they they look good because the
chances of Tyson Fury ever getting abs
is like Rob getting abs over here it's
just not you leave Rob ABS out of this
saying but cardio stamina nothing no he
has cardio Tyson to be able to box 12
do you know his story do you know
anything about what you're talking about
with Tyson like do you know what this
guy did who I need know his higher
background to know that he's
got I I'm I'm familiar with Tyson Fury
there's probably the things you'll
enlighten me on but no no I'm just
saying like his story is the ultimate
story comeback Redemption the Father the
family who they were growing up in the
streets what the father was known for
this this is a Fighters family like
they're a the the oh I've seen his
father his brother his brother's the
best shaped guy I've ever freaking seen
fighting yeah he's in shape as well but
no disrespect to Tyson I root for the
guy I'm a fan he's a beast I'm just
curious about the the part that was
interesting is his father named him
after Tyson Mike Tyson yeah he knew and
and Tyson still chose to be in Francis
and gano's Corner WoW instead of Tyson
Fury and Francis oh Mike Tyson doesn't
owe him loyalty I get that all I'm
saying no no what I'm saying is though
mean that's that was part of the story
it was part of the story you needed for
the fight right it was kind of like look
no doubt you chose this guy's name but
he's going to the other guy's corner it
was to some people they wanted Tyson to
destroy Francis to some people are like
dude Francis is gonna what if he becomes
to come back you know he Underdog and
does what he does that father himself is
one of the most like entertaining guys
out we talked about The Ball Brothers
Lavar ball that I don't even know what
the father's doing these days the father
you saw he he flipped up the table
before the a showman he's a showman he's
a showman yeah I mean they understand
they they you know they know what what
they're there for Usman good move
Francis leaving UFC to go into
boxing right now of course it seemed
that way for sure you know um I think
for Francis it wasn't necessarily about
because Francis was a I think was a star
you know I've known Francis who since
his first fight in the UFC and we've
been close and I've you know that's like
that's like my brother I always you know
got his back
and and always will and so he's always
been a star to me and it was just a
matter of time for the world recognized
it but um I think he was going to get
there eventually I think it for him it
was about
Freedom it was is having that you know
he's he's had a interest in very very
interest in life so to feel that that
freedom to be able to do what he wanted
to do as an athlete cuz we give so much
of ourselves to this I think that that's
really what it was about for him and now
he has it he can box if he wants he can
do mixed martial arts if he wants and
that I think is the big win for him I am
so curious to
know how he's going to train now that he
knows like you know when he said Fury
comes up to him and he says I'm going to
you know you're going to be a student
I'm going to teach you a lesson or
whatever the oh yeah I actually saw it
cuz I was in I was in the ring so we're
getting out of the ring yeah and um so
Fury goes uh in his accent get ready to
go to school son you know in his accent
and and I didn't know if Francis heard
it but I heard it you know listening to
I I'm getting out of the ring before the
fight and I hear him say it oh co cool
you know it's just oh you don't know
Francis heard it I didn't know Francis
heard it but I I I heard uh so did you
tell Fran hey just
F talking [__] he said he's going to
take you to
school no no not at all I just um I
heard him say and I'm just like I mean
it's just what you know you're in a
competitive mode like he's ready to go
and it was just you know just before I
even touch on that it was just something
that there's an energy that you feel
right when you're about to when guys are
about to compete and not just and this
is not like any other sports like it's
different this is not a game that we're
playing guys are about to
fight there's an energy that you you you
just see two they they turn into humans
you see two humans and it's a spirit
that obviously I'm used to seeing now
but I'm in there with them and you just
it's like strip everything away you just
see two kids in here about to and the
little boys they're about to fight
something's about to happen and I the
first time because you you from from
afar you see Tyson Fury is these big
massive star this this
competitor and I see him in there and
then the nervousness and and and all of
this with all the guys with both guys
him and Francis you see it and then he
says that and when he he's saying so I'm
I'm seeing this from him because I you
know I'm a fighter as well so I
recognize what's going what's happening
the the energy that I'm feeling I see it
and I'm and then he says that I'm like
oh okay he's competitor he's trying to
compete trying to get one more word in
to maybe mess with your head and get you
to to not be locked in like that but
then Francis comes out and you know I
knew Francis I that's I've said it to
left though with a left yeah I mean
Francis has uh insane power and it
wasn't even full contact it didn't make
AKA full no I if fry hits any I think
fry punches a rhino on the side of the
head
that that rh's going to see who the hell
was that is he the hardest puncher out
there these days yeah he has the actual
Guinness World Record for the oh damn
yeah when he was here that was about a
year and a half ago he had his leg was
messed up his leg was messed upar who
who's the hardest in your career that
you felt power hitting you who was the
strongest that
hit I mean I've made I've made a career
of not really being hit in there much
until I took the kick that that ended my
Title reign but uh I would in a fight
not not I've never been taking a full on
like strength like who who would you say
like is like the prac I've been hit who
practice uh I I would there's a Francis
has I've actually sparred with Francis a
little bit and he and he wasn't going
full out but still I I felt what that
was like to to run in cuz I I did take a
Punch To The Head and I ran into that I
was like yeah that's not good what the
weight so what's the weight size
difference between you guys well I'm
about 190 lbs and Francis is is all
27 just rock and you saw his build right
there and I and I I I took a jab and I
was just like you took a jab yeah I took
a jab and it cracked my neck oh s dude I
felt it just and it I took it to the
forehead too which is not a place you
relatively want to punch another guy
because you could break your hand and I
took that jab and I was just like neck
cracked I was like I don't I didn't like
that that and can we not do that again
look at that say Anthony Johnson Anthony
Johnson the late my buddy the late
Anthony Johnson Rumble Johnson Anthony
was probably one of the hardest hit guys
really it was just something about the
way these guys stand the way they
deliver a punch and you know they
Anthony was at one point got high
violent yeah was ranked one of the most
violent he had who has who was The
Knockout cuz he had one that was uh he
he had many he had Glover toera knocked
his tooth out in there he had a
uh Alexander augustas knocked him out in
Sweden he had uh who else he he was just
not knocking ton of guys
out by the way he's had some if we asked
mvol who hits the hardest do you think
he'd say you that was a brutal knockout
D Mas doll's had a lot of fights and
that's the thing he's a veteran he's had
a ton of fights he he used to I'm from
Miami he used to fight
Miami what was knuckle you know it was
uh oh Kimbo Slice those fight things to
do H out there wild yeah so you don't
think that your knockout which was
Savage by the way you don't think that
would qualify as his hard I don't know
he might not remember what it felt like
you know like that's the thing with as
as a and you said that with Leon you
said I didn't know for 20 minutes you
were at no see I'm yeah that's it's such
a weird weird the human body is just so
crazy and insane so I think I was down
for I mean I was I was down for maybe
like you know 30 30 seconds cuz I I
wasn't really like out cold you know I
was out but I was my eyes were open and
I was there which is is even
crazier um so I get up after like a 45
seconds a minute I'm standing up and
talking to my coaches and I'm you know
they're talking to me and I'm I'm there
you see the the the interaction I'm
there I'm talking to
them but your brain's not on yet I mean
it's it's it's it's it's it's almost
like boom you're rebooting the computer
shut down you have it turned on your
computer's on you see the Apple sign or
whatnot but it's not necessarily firing
you know the way it needs to go you're
not sending emails at that point you
know you're still waiting for it to
reboot so that whole process is
autopilot I'm in there I'm talking to my
coaches that's autopilot I shake his
hand I give him his props I walk out I'm
in the back in the in the do you know
doctor's tent saw autopilot I'm there my
family's there I'm like tell them I'm
good I'm yeah everything's fine good
good boom they're like all right yeah
you look fine but just for precaution
let's just go in the ambulance just go
to the hospital and get just get a scan
just for precaution fine I don't know
why you know but we're in there all this
is probably a 15 to 20 minute
transition I'm sitting in the
ambulance and I get dve my jacket and
they take off so we're in the ambulance
and so they're doing their routines I'm
just sitting in there with me and my
manager and they're doing the routine
and they they're asking okay so do you
know you know where you're at and it's
at that
moment I remember actual
thought not what I've been not what I've
seen or what I've been told or what I
I've cuz when you see it you start to
put yourself there but remember actual
thought like do you know where you're at
I'm like yeah of course I know where I'm
at yeah I'm in Salt Lake City UFC
278 like okay do you remember I'm like
oh [__] oh no were you in Salt Lake City
damn I'm in an ambulance oh oh my God
that can't be good so that's when you
you it comes to you damn and I I think I
uh I've even heard I haven't seen it but
even Michael Bisping after his knockout
versus uh Dan Henderson when Dan
Henderson knocked him out which was a
vicious Knockout by the way he was in
the showers got ready and then he's
asking him yo when are we when are we
fighting when's the
fight oh wow so he didn't even know he
had finished fighting and all of that
just this why you got to respect these
guys and what they do can I tell you a
quick bisbing story and this is actually
a question for you so I'm at a hotel in
New York a high-end hotel and I'm there
with a girl at the time the room next
door is Michael bisbing right and he's
there with his buddy and they're like
locked out of their room long story
short we end up we end up like getting
some bottles I I knew some other people
Hotel I'm partying with Michael bisbing
and his buddy it was just it was
hilarious so anyway he likes to party um
yeah cool guy cool guy fun guy um
lifestyle right we just talked about
boxing that's the work side of things
right so you know everyone's obsessed
these days with work life balance you
know I'm more of the 8020 Camp I work
80% of the time 20% of the time weekend
warrior you know you were at the Soho
house party we did a week or so ago it
was sick it was awesome saw you on the
roof I saw you at the tent you're having
fun people you know everyone's living a
having a good time how do you manage
your work life balance when do you party
when do you train when do you live your
life how do you handle all that h i mean
it's it's a it's a tough a very tough
thing to do you know um especially when
you're when you're an athlete I guess a
public figure now it's difficult like I
said I was never into the whole famous
thing being seen and all of that so I
don't spend that much time in Miami I've
been living down in South Florida now
since
2012 and I've probably been in my Miami
less than 50 times but you're in bokeh I
think you've been at the Hy jinkx before
I'm in the Palm Beach area okay got you
all
right but it it's um yeah I just but not
even Miami partying but just going out
having dinner going to a bar having
another good you know lifestyle that's
what so that's what you you know you
always want that that's what I was like
oh man I want to get to where I could
just eat wherever and do whatever and
and I I like that you know I love to be
able to take my kids and my you know my
lady and my friends you know to hang out
but it's it's different now because
everywhere you go now there's a phone in
your face yeah someone has a phone in
your face so and what people don't
realize is especially when you deal with
like people like obviously Kanye is an
extreme you know extreme measure
but that takes away from the enjoyment
of it all like you can go you can go
somewhere like you said with with
Bisping and you guys are just partying
just having a great time that's great
you know it's an intimate moment you
guys just chilling hanging out that's
fun but as soon as someone pulls a
camera out into your face it just
destroys the fun because it's like why
do we need to document this this is
documented up here we're actually living
it we're having a great time so people
aren't necessarily living to live
anymore they're living for what I can
show other people
and that that takes away from it and it
makes me just want to stay at my house I
was always been a home body anyways but
you know I don't enjoy it as much
because as soon as I'm sitting there
they're eating and you know I'm having a
great time mhm and then now you look
over and someone's recording
you now I it changed don't you have to
take the good with the bad like I'll
give you a scenario you know what's even
worse you're sitting there at a dinner
and zero people want to come up to you
nobody recognizes you no one wants to
take a picture but that but that means
that you didn't really reach your star
status so you know yeah but it kind of
comes with the territory doesn't it it
no for for sure it comes with the
territory but at the end of the day like
we mentioned earlier in the show we're
all human beings we still want to be
left alone because I'm a human being and
yes I could be the biggest star in the
world but I'm still a human being which
you know my dog might have passed
yesterday or my my grandma might have
passed or my aunt might have passed so
I'm I'm actually dealing with human
emotions here and I'm feeling all those
things right and I don't necessarily
want to be on camera right now but you
don't care because all you care about is
the interaction that You' dream up in
your head that you would have if you
actually ever got to see me so I think
that the hard part is learning the
balance that which you know I think I've
been doing a pretty decent job of is
understanding that yeah people have this
expectation of you when they meet you of
who who you are how you are so being
able to at least give them a little bit
of that but still being the human that
you are I will say this from having
talked to a lot of the guys in in your
world seem very self-aware
and you're you you think with your
answer you you don't give the Diplomatic
answer you'll give the straight up
answer but you're also respectful about
it so you're I don't know if you have
any desire to get into politics one day
but in a in a way that you communicate
it's it's uh it's very interesting the
way you communicate it's it's different
and uh uh respect you and by the way
this brings me to the last thing so this
one video was going viral during uh this
last UFC fight can you pull it up the
one way to go okay play this clip I want
to get cuz you've had some moments with
the president Trump and Trump and UFC
kind of go hand inand so this guy's
going around asking different fighters
who they think would have won the fight
between Trump and Biden and this is what
the response is go
ahead you got the audio because I can't
hear it Rob on do you hear it or no I
don't hear it's up on our end I don't
know why it's the production team guys
in the back hear it uh yank do you guys
in the
back maybe test audio off and come back
on and see maybe if that does that
sometime this happen Trump or Joe Biden
oh my gosh Donald Trump would knock out
Joe Biden within literally 5 Seconds oh
Donald Trump had absolutely kill Joe
Biden Joe Biden can't even get down the
stairs ly fall down him and he's walking
Trump 100% Donald Trump I think Donald
Trump off the top of the cage is just
pile drives sliding into the floor
literally Donald Trump would knock him
out with his lunch boox for hands if
you've ever seen his hands that guy is
freaking massive and and he used to
wrestle so he's a real fighter yeah I
probably go Trump's too old now 100%
Donal Trump Joe Biden is too old bro I'm
sorry Trump would punch his face in you
see Joe Biden can't even ride a bicycle
he's falling off his bicycle I mean the
guy can't even walk up a fight of stairs
he wouldn't make it into the Octagon
maybe he go to the wrong direction I
don't
know Donald Trump KO Joe Biden within
seconds that old man in your profession
what do you think if Trump and Biden got
my God are you going to give us a
diplomatic answer what answer are you
going to give us if those guys
fought well a fight with both guys would
be very
expensive and so so Trump understands
this you know we they that that those
that's not a fisticuff type of fight
that's wallet fight at that point so I
don't think we'll be seeing both of
those guys throw hands but I think
uh I think just uh Trump is just still a
little bit more active I think so he's a
little bit more active really witty
witty guy it's sharper than most people
think because when you put the camera in
his face it you know it comes off a
certain way but uh sharper much sharper
than most people what's your interaction
been with him play one of the clips I
don't know which one it is that you got
you found one of them uh uh is this the
one no play yeah play the other one play
the other one what's that this one right
here Camaro Usman where is uh where is
our champ come on champ get up man oh
man oh
man what a fighter you are I don't want
to mess with him what's your
relationship with them you know I've met
the guy um you know it's
uh like I said when that camera's on
it's a
it's and the media paints whatever
picture they want to paint of the guy
obviously I'm not deep into politics I
just know how it affects me in my
pockets MH and and my family with the
policies and the laws that are being
made and so it it's it's difficult when
the media is saying a certain thing and
they they're painting this picture and
that's all you have to go on and so a
lot of people just kind of follow what
what's being told but now being in the
position to where I'm I'm high enough to
where I'm directly affected by those
policies and some of those things that
are being made you know now you you
start to kind of think a little bit more
more for yourself like wait you know
this is what the media said yesterday
but they lied to us but this is what's
what's really happening and so it kind
of you know light bulb goes off and now
you start to kind of really dive in a
little bit more but my interaction with
him is he's always been cool with me
and let me touch on this it was when he
was
president there's of course he you know
like I don't want to say he's not the
best communicator when he's on in front
of that screen he's not the best the
message doesn't come across the best way
possible and so this picture is painted
of who this guy is and so you feel a
certain way you know it hits your
heartstrings a lot different and
especially the time where the world is
going through so much chaos and so many
different things and so then getting to
actually be in front of the guy and
actually you know hear the guy and I'm
I'm I'm one of those that I I hold a man
by his word so if you say certain things
to me then that's that's what I expect
and it was a lot different than
definitely what I expect because I you
know at some point based on what the
media is paying is you I expect to give
them piece of my mind like this is how I
feel interesting and then it's it
doesn't go quite like that so then you
you start to kind of I think that's a
skill as well as being a man as you
start to kind of be able to assess and
re-evaluate what you might have thought
and be open to knowing that you know
what I can't change what I was thinking
and my views on someone but you know
definitely was a lot different than what
I was expecting I was expecting him to
be a lot slower than he actually was but
he was very witty Shari reminded me a
lot of my my high school wrestling coach
they very remind you of your high school
wrestling coach oh yeah they're very
they're very witty with words very sharp
about the environment what's going on
they they know and so that's what what
what really shocked me were you more of
a of an Obama guy before Trump of course
of course um I'm not going to lie
100% um just based on the representation
based on what he he meant you know was
was was big so by that alone default I
was an Obama guy you know but then you
like I said when you you get to a
certain level you ascend to a certain
level then you realize how direct things
affect you and it's like well I worked
for this why why why why can't everybody
else work you were an Obama guy
obviously Biden was his VP is that by
default are you a Biden guy now or how
does that work well they say never
discuss politics right well because it's
in deniable come I mean you can't you
can't deny it but I but I think Usman
you answered it I think I think you
answered it I think if the if the
viewers listening you you gave the
answer I think you went through a little
bit of Usman I think you and Usman have
I mean look me and Usman were the same
guy yeah but but it is interesting Pat
because it is Nightmare it is it's it's
undeniable of this past four three and a
half or three years like it's undeniable
and I think it's amazing that you're
saying it kamaro that it's even if
you're not really into the politics or
anything you feel it you see it it's
embedded all the changes that are
happening we are not in good shape it's
not getting better and I mean we're not
doing politics no we're not I'm not
dude can I tell you something I think
America relates more to him and and what
I mean by that is like when I first got
into sales you know we've always voted
Democrat it's always been what we were
I'm Armenian Assyrian we're from Iran
it's like you know the rich or
Republicans are for the rich the
Democrats are for the poor and then you
go into sales you work you're like wait
a minute how come that you're leaving
home early and I need to pay for your
stuff why why don't you stick around
late and train for this I don't feel
sorry for you why why why am I getting
punished for me working twice the amount
of hours as you then you realize dude no
man the same way in the gym that guy's
getting this and he's get the better
Locker than me and I'm here twice as
many times small little experiences like
this you start realizing that those
policies just don't work and sometimes
that takes a decade or two for some to
figure that out Usman this has been a
blast thank you having you on brother
it's been a pleasure really enjoy
getting to know you even more um you're
very interesting uh you're very
interesting very self-aware like I said
earlier your answers you'll give the
answer but you're going to give the
answer based on the way you view it and
it's smooth your answers but I really
really enjoy this and I'm looking
forward to doing it again in the future
brother thank you so much for coming on
gang take care I think we got a podcast
Rob tomorrow and we got one on I think
Thursday is actually Kobe coming here is
Thursday Kobe comington on Thursday and
tomorrow home team with Emily Austin
okay so that'll be tomorrow that should
be interesting yes take care everybody
bye bye-bye who's
that